. I want you to take a look at this clip of
billionaire Robert Elf Smith as he spoke at
an Hbcu, a historically black college and
university Morehouse college here in Atlanta,
Georgia.
And um, gave these graduating students the
graduation gift of a lifetime.
Take a listen in
on behalf of the eight generations of my family
who have been in this country, we're going
to put a little fuel in your bus.
Now I've got the alumni over there and this
is the challenge to you alumni.
This is my class 2019
[inaudible]
and my family is making a grant to eliminate
their student loans.
[inaudible] now
listen, this is, this is amazing.
There's a lot to say and I'm going to say
everything I trust me, there's a lot to quote
unquote analyze about this.
But first and foremost, shout out to all those
graduating students who don't have to worry
about Sallie Mae.
Tracking them down.
Shout out to all those people who don't have
to say, um, you know, I think I'm going to
go back to college so I don't have to pay
my student loans because I can't afford to
pay them this semester.
So maybe I'll go to college and take out another
loan just so that I can differ what I have
to pay back.
So this is a great story because there's 400
guys.
Uh, it's an all male college, uh, who now
have an opportunity to do something with their
lives without worrying about having a $100,000
worth of debt.
And that's how much each of them are estimated
to have $100,000 in debt for a bachelors degree.
Let's talk the serious side of this conversation.
Robert Smith is committing himself to paying
$40 million.
He and his family, mind you, he and his family,
40 million, almost a billion, $40 million
to pay off the debt for 400 students.
First of all, Robert and your family, Mr.
Smith and your family.
Thank you.
Second of all, why the hell does it call so
much for us to get an education in this country?
I want to play a, I want to put a tweet on
the screen from Barack Obama.
Um, this is what he had to say about it.
He said, quote, here's a great story.
While we've still got a lot of work to do
to make college affordable for everyone that
didn't stop Robert F. Smith from seizing an
opportunity to make a difference, he's erasing
the student loan debt for this year's Morehouse
grads.
I got to go one step further.
Mr President, not only should we make it affordable,
but let's go past that.
We need to make it free.
I mean hell, Germany can send their students
to get an education for free.
Undergrad in Germany is completely free if
you're a citizen, if you're not a citizen,
if you're an American citizen and you're visiting
Germany, you go for a highly reduced price.
Can we?
Surely, surely we can do better than Germany
and not saddle students with the hundred thousand
dollars worth of debt by the time they get
done with a bachelor's degree.
If they're going to a private institution,
but I do want to, I mean it's, it's both in,
I mean, we could operate on two wavelength.
This is a great thing that he's doing.
He's a billionaire and he's given away this
money.
A lot of people are looking at and dismissing
his AI ops.
This is just crumbs off the billionaires table.
Yeah, it literally is, right?
But I'm quite sure there's 400 guys all male
college who are grateful that they don't have
to start off life with debt on their back.
But how do we fight this problem in the United
States?
How do we change this paradigm where we have
$1 trillion in student loan debt?
Well, you know, here's another tweet I think
we'll put in perspective from just the guy
on Twitter.
He's just making a casual observation, and
this is what he said.
He said to all of my Morehouse brethren and
HBCU graduates who missed out on Robert Smith's
blessings.
Holla at Elizabeth Warren.
She has a plan for that.
And indeed she does.
She has a plan to reduce, uh, I believe it
was up to $50,000 of your student loan debt.
Uh, for people who make less than a hundred
thousand dollars a year.
That's not everything.
That's not the whole picture.
I wish that she would go a lot further and
just eliminate all the dead.
That's what we would want.
But it's a start.
It's how we get our foot in the door, uh,
to get this, this, this burden off the backs
of millions of Americans who simply are, and
let's, let's put this thing in perspective
folks.
Every person that went to get a degree, they're
doing something specifically to help the United
States of America, right?
So there is a legitimate economic and, and
uh, uh, I, yeah, sociological but specifically
economic reason that the United States should
pay for these degrees because without us going
to get these degrees in this higher education,
we would be at a competitive disadvantage
in the competitive, in the global marketplace.
So every person that goes to a university
and gets a higher, uh, higher education and
gets a degree, we are literally improving
the state of the United States of America.
Right?
So there's, there's plenty of justifications
for this.
But I digress.
That's all the time I have for you today.
Thanks so much for hanging out with me, David.
Have a great time on your vacation.
For the rest of you, I will see you tomorrow.
Moral, uh, and then the 20th time you can
go to the Benjamin Dixon show.com or progressive
army.com and check out my other work.
Have a great day.